Staters are working to discover the
motive than the apparent random murder
of a college student in Maryland a
County judge ordered 22 year-old suspect
Sean Urbanski to be held without bond
yesterday in his first court appearance
the University of Maryland student faces
first and second degree murder charges
he's accused of stabbing and killing
Bowie State University student Richard
Collins the third the FBI is
investigating the incident as a possible
hate crime
Errol Barnett is at the University of
Maryland campus with the tributes to the
victim Errol good morning good morning
Richard Collins the third was supposed
to walk with his Bowie State classmates
today at graduation being held here on
the University of Maryland campus police
say the suspect Shana Bansky didn't know
him and that the stabbing which took
place at that location behind me was
unprovoked hundreds gathered to honor
Richard Collins on the eve of Bowie
State University's graduation
oh boy say there boy we stay many sang
the school song by candlelight
Collins and two friends were standing at
a University of Maryland bus stop early
Saturday morning when investigators say
Shana Bansky approached the group
screaming and stabbed Collins in the
chest Collins died about an hour later
at the hospital when police arrived on
the scene they found a Bansky sitting on
a bench fifty feet from the bus stop
with a knife in his front shirt pocket
in cordovan skis attorney told the judge
his client has no criminal history and
that alcohol and substance abuse may
have been a factor as I begin my
military career
I'll keep each one of you that helped
shape me in my heart and close to my
mind I'll never be a stranger
thank you last Thursday Collins spoke at
his Bowie State commissioning ceremony
where he became a second lieutenant in
the army it's believed Collins and
Urbanski were strangers investigators
are looking at a ban skis ties to a
racist hate group on Facebook called alt
Reich nation that group appears to have
since been taken down
this is the second investigation into a
potential hate crime at the University
of Maryland in less than two months in
April a noose was discovered hanging in
the kitchen of a university fraternity
house on Monday Prince George's County
officials cautioned it's too soon to
know what motivated Saturday stabbing at
this early stage in this investigation
we do not have enough evidence to say
conclusively whether this is a hate
crime a University of Maryland police
tell us they monitor more than 400
surveillance cameras both on and off
campus investigators tell us they do
have surveillance footage of the
stabbing Gail that's going to be very
tough to see I don't know between
Manchester and then this story you're
just standing at the bus stop waiting
it's just the sense business the hate
behind it some days are very tough in
the news business
Erol we thank you though